it was announced earlier this year made
a big splash at e3 and now at comic-con
folks are getting their hands on it
Lords of the Fallen we're gonna take a
look at and Steven skeleton is joining
me on set producer on the game Steven
thanks for coming man thanks for having
me I you guys have we took a look at
your booth on the show floor a little
earlier on our show a couple days ago
and uh you guys have got like a
challenge there for people playing the
game you've got a giveaway get the whole
comic con production yeah yeah we have
you know we have a whole set of ps4s
right in the game that you can come and
check out and put your hands on play the
game uni and if you can beat the level
all the way through the boss you can get
a t-shirt and we also have Harkins
hammer or character main characters
gigantic hammer replica I feel like your
hands are really ya know yeah it's in
decay I can't it's really it's really
annoying yeah and if you go to our
Facebook page there's a link there we
can enter a contest to win win win the
hammer and then it would figure out look
out where to put it with it that's their
problem but Lords of the Fallen its
you're giving away t-shirts of people
who beat that section did you bring a
lot of t-shirts or is it pretty tough
it's pretty tough and we got plenty of
t-shirts but it's a it's a pretty big
challenge because we even actually had a
lot of people coming and checking out
the game which is awesome but you know
only I mean I don't know can't say what
the exact statistics are but only once
in a while to somebody actually get
through without dying at least once no
that's that's the trek you got yet can't
die you can't die you could get through
it you know to die a few times have a
good time yeah not getting the teacher
no shirt so the game Lords the Fallen is
a challenging game yeah yeah it's an
action RPG it's a it's a challenging
game but we want to make it a
challenging but not frustrating mm-hmm
and as uh that seems like a tough line
yeah it's in notes it's a very tough
line but um one of the things that I
think works really well in Lourdes is
the animation system mm-hmm and you can
really see the behavior of the enemies
and you can spend some time observing
them and make tactical decisions based
on what you observe how they behave and
how they indicate how they're going to
come out here well we're going to get a
look at it right now in action and by
first off we see our well I hesitate to
call him a hero but protagonist
harken yeah that's it that's your
character hearken and engaged in a
combat here and yeah and you can see
that the animation system is like really
nice and smooth and and the characters
give a nice indication about maybe what
direction they're going to swing what
direction they're going to stab so you
have a chance to actually react to it
without getting immediately clobbered
and then whack them with your glowing
yeah there's a lot of that which is yeah
it looks like a cleric class weapon okay
so there's a couple different it's one
character but you can play him in a
couple different yeah essentially
there's there's three base classes of
warrior cleric and rogue and those
determine your magical set of magical
abilities and that's going to get locked
into for the for the game but any
equipment you come across any weapons or
armor anything like that you can use you
can mix and match so there's no cleric
only Road yeah they have to Claire if
you're a claret class you can put on
more your armor and use Road weapons and
you can mix and match to your heart's
delight you know however you wanna
however you want to apply very cool so
we it looks like we jumped to another
area because they were seeing the sword
now is the action and the shield which I
was gonna comment on earlier did that
just it just looked like a gaping to
theme aw yeah that's kind of what the
shoulder pads now look like yeah not so
that's their problem part of the same
set oh so um but yeah you're not you're
not restricted to using the same set
there were there we go you can kind of
see you know you can switch out all your
different all the equipment you found
you know whether it's you know weapons
or armor or anything like that and
choose what you want and your character
will change in your character's
appearance will change goes old and of
course you know um you know the heavier
the weapon or armor of the mall and
covered you are a little bit even a
little bit slower maybe got my
protection so there's the train'll so
some sort of familiar balances and and
trade-offs as he said in terms of the
armor that you guys are bringing in what
is it you know this is the kind of game
that people are familiar with and have a
lot of passion for what sort of what do
you guys sort of targeting in the Lords
of the Fallen to help it sort of carve
out its own niche well I with orders of
the phone what what we're doing is
you know first going for a challenging
but not frustrating combat experience
and second we have a bit more focus on a
strong narrative in the character story
okay um so it's a you know harken your
character is brought into this conflict
because thousands of years ago humanity
had this huge fight with his evil God
and defeated the God and everybody
thought great we eliminated evil from
the world tonight anytime somebody
commits a sin we're just gonna brand
them an outcast and put a tattoo on
their face and yeah check him out send
him out yeah and but this evil gods
forces have been returning to earth and
nobody knows why and they figure let's
fight evil with evil let's find the
worst of the worst the baddest dude
being behind that's committed the most
sins and set him on this quest to figure
out what's going on and stop it and
that's you so you are a real salty dude
yeah and yeah you are fighting a lot of
overdue library books yeah yeah yeahs
parking ticket yes just oh my goodness
oh yeah so you're real yeah you're a
real a bad dude real tough and it's your
job to a stop these forces and then be
figure out why they're coming back and
ultimately trying to stop if you're such
a bad dude why do you care though man
like what that's we're just like look
you guys branded me a city tattoo my
face forget you well hell yeah well I
mean the trade-off is like hey you know
you do this then you can rejoin society
and your current but it's also you'll
find out the story is a little bit of a
turn to wear as you progress through the
game you'll start to find clues that
like well maybe this people dog wasn't
so easy
maybe you shouldn't have been banished
and maybe I will or will not try and
rebandage this guy alright maybe this
infiltrator is like pooping out horrible
blade puddle yeah is it such a bad guy
said well yeah I gotta say this thing is
grossing me out and yeah I kind of like
it is that weird yeah no I mean there's
there's a lot of these different
creatures are really kind of awesome and
unique and yeah this guy I dig I
realized we had a giant two females were
so fantastic it just keeps getting
better I are you guys is that sort of
grotesquerie like part of the one of the
design things are sort of focusing on in
terms of creating that world well it's
it's you know it's it's creating like a
unique creature that stands alone by
itself that's also distinct from a lot
of the other like major bosses which are
the Lords of this falling got all the
generals of his army okay is with the
hood the lord so you're not the Lord
you're now you're fighting or so and so
to make each one of these guys as unique
as an interesting as possible so you
know there's yeah there's that guy you
know who's you know the tripod a spider
crazy thing and there's a guy that's
earlier who's more of kind of like a
traditional giant armored guy okay was
really menacing so got a lot different
variety he doesn't necessarily squirt
things out that then grow on the floor
now but he's got some really cool
attacks when you get him hurt pretty bad
he gets really angry and tears offals
armor and then just starts going crazy
doesn't seem prudent but I guess sangria
tiny lord of the Fallen without knowing
a thing or two about killing things that
speaking of there was a few moments we
saw there that was sort of like
execution moments or something a little
earlier on just so the the enemy
behavior changes over the course of the
battle yeah in some ways yeah and it's
also in its in as you're fighting
depending I mean you can you can execute
timed combos um that will you know that
will you chain into some of those kind
of specific attacks ok so you yourself
this now do those combos are those
things you kind of learn are they weapon
dependent are they just kind of a
general attack pattern it sits in a
pattern and kind of and based on you
know position and timing where you are
in relation to the enemy and then it
will take in okay cool so it seems like
you know you guys have you have sort of
the the evil vs maybe good story stuff
going on you've got a couple inflection
points in this story but seems like a
lot of your focus is on that combat well
yeah I mean that's that's the core of
the game I mean that's the heart of the
game is the you know is the intense
tactical combat one on one or a couple
on a couple on one so it's never gonna
be like you know a hundred guys comin hi
reach your whack whack whack whack it's
very attacked play you need to be
engaged with that enemy and you know
sort of reading them and reacting to
them as opposed to just threshing your
way yeah you don't get too far just
running in and starting to a hackle a
very cool are there any other sort of
modes you guys are putting in here in
addition to sort of the main thrust of
the campaign um know what I mean that's
that's that that's the main game itself
there like side quests and stuff that
you'll find so okay in how the in how
the game is structured so it's kind of a
network hub structure so there's a
there's a central monastery that you
keep returning to and finding new bits
and pieces of the story and equipment in
areas and then as you go out to
different areas oh so you can kind of
choose which areas you a little bit yeah
a little bit of that so and there's also
with the the limited edition which if
you preorder that you automatically get
bumped up north america south america
you get pumped up to the de limited
edition nice and that includes a dlc
package which has an additional quest
mhm and demonic weapon set which gives
you a set of daggers and a sword and a
hammer in the soundtrack just some
normal looking daggers though I mean no
their demand okay they're demonic and as
we saw they made more normal of demonic
daggers sure certainly have a flair for
the dramatic I guess so folks who are
interested in the game what platform is
it coming out it's coming out for
next-gen systems so xbox one playstation
4 and PC next alright very cool is that
head and you guys are targeting a
release this year or like early next
week number 28 I'm October 28 not even a
target yeah that's right that's right
yeah very cool i think i've got a
question or two coming in here let me
just check out real quick uh while we're
doing that
tell me a little bit more about uh
Harkin and this sort of I mean does he
do you get to know him as a character or
D is he sort of you the player as a
carrot no I mean there's a voice actor
yeah they got ya know he's got voice
acting there's a character and their
their story element and cutscenes that
you'll find throughout the game that'll
kind of illustrate in his backstory and
what is currently happening to him so
yeah you're you're driving him um but
you also you know get his character all
right and we've got a question coming in
over Twitter wondering about actually
the character choices because that's I
feel like that's that's something that
people like really sort of perk up that
yeah is I can I can choose I can make a
game different for myself you know it
might want to replay it like it are
there many of those sort of sort of
moments or is it just kind of at the end
you decided that the fate of the whole
world well no I mean the the the you
know at the end there's there's a couple
of ways to story can end so you can go
back and you can you can play it a
little bit differently okay or you can
go back if you want to like hey I want
to redo it as as the warrior class you
know there's a three different classes
so you can you know you can play through
it with three different classes and the
three different sets of magical
abilities I might sell and the magical
abilities we saw I think felt like most
of the attacks were seeing were melee
based world how much how much sort of is
a balance between melee and magic in
your attack pattern um well the magic is
really meant as kind of like your big
gun okay so your it's meant to be used
once in a while as opposed to the the
weapons which are your primaries so
they're basically you know the magic is
used is like okay I need don't need help
to get out as a bad situation or I you
know I want to use it very tactically to
whittle down a bad guy and there's
actually another question coming in
about the magic for each class that's
that that's the distinguishing ya point
really so can you give us an example of
how those are delineated well it's it's
basically you know you can you can
probably imagine from the different
classes you know oh you know warriors
more offensive types of magic the cleric
is more defensive and kind of like one
of his things as you know he can create
duplicates of himself that will fool
enemies oh it's really good to use like
some some of the guys you can get behind
a guy and
get them and the thief is a little more
stealthy so it's kind of its kind of
kind of go along those lines all right
Stephen well Lords are the fallen coming
out say that date again October 28
October 28 for xbox one ps4 and PC thank
you so much for coming by thanks a lot
showing the game off and talking about
it that's Lords of the Fallen folks if
you want to know more check out gamespot
com we've got a bunch of videos and
articles up on it and get a bigger
meteor taste and it might taste weird
because of all demonic stuff but I think
you'll like it